hey guys Justin Willman backstage at the
Kelly Clarkson show just into magic with
Kelly super fun we're talking about the
new season of my Netflix show magic for
humans super fun now I'm going to make
my escape the magician does saunter out
here thank you to the staff do a trick
yeah okay see this happens when you're a
magician people are 53
even if you're in a hurry or other word
do you have any money I love it honey
yeah $20 bill yay magic watch I just
fold it up here like this a little bit
it gets a little bit smaller and smaller
and gradually that $20 bill just turns
into a $1 bill yeah thank you nice
meeting you
so I love the look on people's face when
you do magic but you know sometimes you
know you just gotta get to where you hey
sorry
hey I scrape your shot no you're great I
thought that was a pleasure where you
were so great thank you not to leave
that trick no idea I wanted that he was
anyone to see it you know I actually do
right here okay honey okay this was the
thing I used to have watch we could take
the the cash here and just hold up the
20 turns into a 1 whoa that sounds great
except
then we've got hey Justin hi when I
guess you trick magic yeah I love magic
okay what did you have given every money
[Music]
okay all right watch the hundred-dollar
bit watch it oh my god Lionel Richie no
thank you very nice meeting you so much
it's magic it's gone so that's you know
that's how I bring smiles to the people
of the Kelly Clarkson show see if they
want to see anything I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this